and now we've got a team of
correspondents standing by with the
latest developments for you harry
fawcett
is in occupied east jerusalem nida
ibrahim
is in ramallah sami abu salam is in gaza
with people who've been displaced
by the bombing and um science is outside
the besieged enclaves main hospital and
we'll start with
her yumna uh you're joining us from
outside the main hospital but
as i understand it there has been an
attack
in the last few minutes very close to
where you're standing
right now just talk our viewers through
what's happened
yes the targeting was for a car just it
happened just 20 minutes ago
i was in my car coming to shifa hospital
the car that was targeted was just 10
meters away from
my car the driver was driving we were
driving
normally and then suddenly the car in
front of us just
in meters away got targeted by a missile
i mean if if his phone hadn't rang so he
had to
you know lower his speed a little bit we
would have been targeted as well we
would have been dead by now
it's it's it's obvious that the israeli
army when they're targeting
their their targets they do not it does
not matter to them
whether there are civilians or uh
whether of children or
uh or normal civilians innocent
civilians
that are around the targeting and these
civilians
get to pay also the price i mean in just
a matter of minutes
i myself could have died along with my
driveway the people in the car with me
along that targeting and and it would
have just been
another justification that it's another
uh
target for them and and as simple as
that
i mean where is the international
community
from these crimes how many civilians
innocent civilians have to pay
the price for this madness that is going
on
okay all through last night we have been
the the gaza strip has been shaking by
very violent uh
raids and shellings artillery shellings
the entire night
i mean every night is just more worse
and more violent than the night before
uh the the martyrs rise the numbers
change in minutes i mean
the last of what the ministry of health
had stated was 198
uh just while i was standing from that
car from that car
three people came out in pieces and and
and one was wounded and then
uh just a couple of minutes later
another person came out
from a targeting for a home so like we
have four more marchers added to that
to that death toll every single minute
there is a new martyr there are new
people who are wounded
okay you know we're obviously uh here in
doha very relieved
that you are still with us and
i understand you must be going through
quite a bit of shock so i appreciate
that you're staying on air
to talk to us right now just
uh if you could update our viewers uh
just of this situation that that is
happening in the the al-shifa hospital
uh behind you certainly when we were
talking before we went live
with this show we saw more people
getting carried out on makeshift
stretchers from the hospital
just set the scene for us that's gaza's
largest hospital
what are the conditions like in there
because
we're at a stage now where power is
running low
and that water is running low how's that
impacting the hospital where you are
this is gaza's largest hospital it's a
complex it has
lots of departments all departments
including administration offices
including receptions they're all filled
with beds
who have either pa patients who are
either wounded or
or in difficult conditions we already
have the crisis of the corona going on
and and and the resources of the medical
sector
in gaza strip is already very fragile
due to the ongoing siege 15 years of
siege until now
and the very very accurate uh medical
requirements and
and resources that they have the
corridors have
beds since like three days ago beds have
been added also in the corridors
uh some some in some of the scenes uh
mattresses have been put on the floor
for the amount to to take more more
patients
in i mean uh with with such with such
intensity in the amount of people who
come to the hospital
every now and then either in difficult
conditions
or wounded heavily wounded or immediate
wounded
i think that the the health sector is
not going to hold
uh more than that there there is a great
crisis
in the electricity i mean uh the
the entire gaza strip now is getting
from an hour to three hours
at best conditions of electricity
the generators have a very huge lack of
fuel now so they have also uh today
there was a statement
for um the generators unity here in gaza
strip
saying that they will really shortage
the amount of hours
that they would be providing electricity
through generators because of the lack
of fuel
okay so now we have a crisis of
electricity
because of the great damaging that has
happened in all the power lines
and that has caused great charge
outages in power and and now we have
lack of fuel
so we have lack of also electricity from
generators
uh the the situation just keeps on
getting compounded and compounded by
crisis
i mean uh uh where like where is the
international community acting from
all that is going on with the gaza strip
targeting has has reached medical
centers
and and and and hospitals yesterday
there was a land that was just
right here very very close to a ship a
hospital
it was uh and and the house was actually
warned yesterday
azure family house which is just around
the complex
it has been targeted yesterday not the
house but the land next to it
so this targeting has caused also a
great great uh
traumatizing to the people in the
hospital i mean uh
most most uh medias uh are broadcasting
from the shifa
because assuming this is the safest
place that we can
uh um broadcast from the infrastructure
is severely
damaged around the hospitals in the
entire gaza strip not just
a shift hospital in gaza city but the
entire gaza strip
the roads have been severely damaged and
destructed
which eliminates the amounts and
the the the the capability
of the civil defense and emergency crews
to reach to the people who have been
targeted the homes that keep on getting
targeted
every now and then so there as i was
saying the
the situation is just getting compounded
by crisis every now and then
it's just getting more and more worse
it's uh it's very
distressing uh testimony that you're
reporting for us
there yuma al-sayed we will
let you get back to it take a break
very relieved to hear that you are saved
after a car
in front of you as you were traveling to
that live spot
was bombed thank you uh yumna al-sayed
reporting there from outside the
al-shifa hospital because of course
the al jazeera and the ap offices were
destroyed
on saturday